c'était pendant des décennies le cœur du
quartier view ville mais les paroissiens
ont quitté et des clôtures ont pris la
place dans l'église construite en 1902
une énorme fissure fermée depuis 2009
Saint-Clément n'est même plus chauffé on
le voit se détériorer l'extérieur fait
qu'on se barre il faut prendre
l'autoroute par les cornes un groupe de
citoyens s'est formé pour rescaper le
splendide bâtiment né au roman nous ce
qu'on veut faire c'est ré-ouvrir
l'église redonner accès au bâtiment pour
les gens du quartier pour justement
redonner vie au bâtiment dehors mais
aussi de se rassembler d'avoir un espace
où par exemple les enfants peuvent
pratiquer du sport au sous-sol les
parents prennent un café en haut autant
les enfants que les grands-parents ont
envie de venir pour faire des activités
prendre un café etc
on sent que les gens ont envie
d'embarquer là-dedans puis quand on
parle à des potentiels partenaires
financiers eux aussi comprennent mais le
temps commence à tu avais la statue de
la Vierge Marie qui est qui était en
haut du confessionnal depuis notre
première visite au mois de mars une
statue s'est effondrée avec l'ancien
confessionnal on peut pas
éliminer ces existes dans les quartiers
Félix Lambert pense qu'il faut redonner
au plus belles églises une partie de
leur vocation initiale il faut que
quelque part où on se sent si c'est pas
la religion c'est peut-être la musique
des conférences les choses comme ça où
les gens
par des idées mais le défi écolossal
avec la pandémie les croyants étant
devenus plus rares les revenus ont
baissé il déclin du patrimoine religieux
c'est donc accéléré en 2020 au Québec
699 lieu de culte était en mutation soit
environ 25% du total deux ans plus tard
on en compte 762 soit environ 28% du
total je crois que toi même avec Québec
c'est que il y a pas assez de
force à passer de
d'argent Québec investit chaque année
environ 25 millions pour rénover et
requalifier les bâtiments religieux mais
uniquement à Saint-Clément une
requalification coûterait probablement
plus de 10 millions on est aussi en
train de faire le patrimoine qu'on va
laisser aux générations futures et
peut-être que on serait pas à la hauteur
si tout ce qu'on laissait c'est un
paquet de vieilles photos dans des
livres d'histoire en disant voici ce que
nous avions même si nous cherchons
encore de l'argent pour évaluer
l'ampleur du projet les citoyens du
quartier restent optimiste je pense
qu'il y a un certain momentum au niveau
de la du redéveloppement de la
requalification des bâtiments de culte
au Québec
on sent que les gens commencent à
comprendre l'importance de préserver le
patrimoine ici David Genki les
Radio-Canada Montréal